today we're gonna be matching some weird
Amazon products to some equally weird
Amazon reviews and we'll we're gonna see
if we get the right enough
[Music]
I can give this a million stars I would
I love it so much I couldn't even bring
myself to use it I drew a face on it
now it's my friend and I have a little
over 40 of them I am soon ordering more
I love you their gift from God it's not
really crafting with cat hair you can't
draw a face on a vacuum or a book I feel
like I had you let's just go eliminate I
hope it's not that pickle you couldn't
draw a face on a sponge and if you are a
good budgeter you can get 40 sponges for
quite a good price I would draw a face
on these because it's like funds above
purchase this and gave it to Weird Al
Yankovic as a gift he liked it so much
he posted it to his Twitter and
Instagram
if the weirdest guy on the planet
approves how can you go wrong highly
recommended or could it be the head game
oh I didn't oh that's good
he's weird it's either this yodeling pic
hole or in the head games review number
three this is probably the most awesome
Christmas gift I could ever give my
four-year-old I was gonna go for the
head games I just think you know that's
too obvious I can see it for your old
dude I'm living life right now I'm 25
and I'll live life with this thing wait
wait wait wait context glue this is
first fixed and uh wait look at the girl
in the box
I'm gonna have to say screw the age gap
and just give your four-year-old son
balls to throw at his head sweet you're
high in question my twenty-something
kids loved it I'm the odd play with this
I'm 20-something I could do this we
could take this off like take it out of
the box like Hollywood put it on so yes
definitely review for me this would be a
cool gift to like Oh congrats on your
new apartment here's a banana slicer
review five I use this with my cat
Dwight once a week it's a win for both
of us I don't think it's the obvious cat
book I don't have a cat me either I had
a dog it's gotta be crafty with your
got here I think maybe the 27 kids like
this and the cats like Dwight the cat
likes this I purchased this because I
was tired of people sitting too near me
on public transport which makes sense
for coconut oil out of all these things
because you can just smush coconut oil
on the seat next to you and people will
slide right off or go look at the team
like it was wet and they won't sit on it
it's a cat book so why basically what
freaked out by kangaroo
I posted this with my ex-wife's account
she hasn't changed a password yet we
bought this a month ago and loved every
moment of it she still does when we went
through the divorce she kept it and left
me the kids oh is it the pickle cuz like
I think it's the pickle weird he gave
weird alda maybe weird allons of bananas
like I think it sounds like some idiot
on Amazon who actually doesn't have a
wife who thinks that this is what his
wife was like it's just like so weird
that and it's so specific like that item
like you wouldn't they wouldn't be like
Oh leave me that like little vacuum
cleaner or the kids like it'd be like
leaving that weird pickle thing or the
kids and they went through a divorce she
might need some lovin right
[Music]
what
[Music]
what no what did the wife gone mange
needs a banana slicer I would buy this
100% I wish it came in a bigger size but
like especially it like you had like
younger kids that you're friends with
like maybe little cousins nieces nephews
like that that'd be a winner or if
you're our age
[Music]